his new book chronicling investment
bubbles through the ages this talk from
the Philadelphia Stock Exchange is 45
minutes thank you good morning as soon
as I get back to New York I'll send mr.
Grasso your regards thank you I'm going
to get into the contents of the book in
a few minutes but one of the things I
like to do very frequently is talk about
some of the stories that have shaped my
thinking about markets and how I've
gotten from some of my original thoughts
two points like this where I started
looking at bigger picture items with
respect to what happens on Wall Street
and and elsewhere around the country at
the regional exchanges and there's a
great story that I picked up many years
ago about a specialist on the floor of
the New York Stock Exchange by the name
of John Coleman he was one of the the
big characters back in the 1950s who
used to walk the floor and fortunately
in this crowd I don't have to explain
what a specialist is but he was one of
the big guys who made markets and stocks
and had a variety of different positions
some proprietary and obviously was
matching buyers and sellers for a living
and as I said he was a grand character
he was very proud individual he had one
of the best specialist firms on the
floor and along with Cardinal Spellman
and the mayor of New York City back at
the time he helped to run New York City
and something of a triumvirate the fact
that his initials were JC and that he
was born on December 24th added to his
self-image just a little bit but he was
this proud character who had a great
business now unfortunately for mr.
Coleman he also had in his employ a
son-in-law who was not the sharpest tool
in the shed as they like to say and as
you guys know back in the back in the
day there were rules against eating on
the floor of the various exchanges
because people didn't want to slip on a
drop piece of food or on some spilled
beverage that might have been there but
the kid always kept something to drink
at his side and coincidentally old man
Coleman not only made a market in
coca-cola of New York which was a
regional bottling company at the time
but also held a proprietary stake in the
firm that was somewhere in early
substantial position for any single firm
to hold and the kid always kept a bottle
of coke at his foot and the old man
would walk back and forth across the
floor and occasionally spot this and
got to the point where he was a little
upset with the young man for having
violated exchange rules on a regular
basis and he owned the stake in
coca-cola New York because he felt that
it was going to at some point in the
future be taken over and he would make a
rather substantial sum of money on that
proprietary state and as time went on he
walked the floor and again finally it
had it with the kid in his penchant for
keeping a drink next to his foot and he
looked at the young man and he said get
rid of the coke and the kids stood up
and said I got 50,000 coke for sale and
was immediately taken out of the
position much to the chagrin of old man
Coleman so that's one story that I very
often used to refute the efficient
market hypothesis where people suppose
that things work as they should on Wall
Street that's one of the stories that
early on kind of got me interested in
the way things really work on the in the
stock market and and there are a whole
host of other stories as some of which
I've written about in other books that
kind of piqued my curiosity as to how
these things happen and what meaning the
markets actually have in a previous book
the message of the markets talked a lot
about how financial markets send signals
about the future shape of the economy
and how if one is very astute and pays
attention to the signals that you get
from the stock market the bond market in
the commodity markets simultaneously you
can be a better informed investor
consumer businessman just by taking
these messages and and listening to what
the market has to say as opposed to what
pundits might have to say about where
the economy is going and it seems in my
mind to be a much better discipline and
a much better approach to this process
of understanding not only markets
directional capabilities but also the
implicit meaning in some of the action
that we see and there's a great story
that they came from art Cashin who as
many of you watch CNBC know has worked
the floor for some 40 years now and has
been at Paine Webber for quite a long
time and he's a good market historian as
well as being a good trader and a good
administrator and a long time ago he
told me a story that really kind of
changed my thinking about the way
markets work and how they send messages
about the future and he was a young
trader at the time in 1963 very young
trader for that matter and was working
his business with a partner and trading
stocks and
then doing what young traders do and
there was a day in late November of 1963
that his partner looked at him and said
hey have you seen anything about the
president that would explain why the
stock market is say taken a sudden
downturn this happened on a friday
afternoon November 22nd 1963 and art
couldn't find anything on the wires to
explain why the markets had taken this
sudden turn and not that it wasn't the
tumultuous week for those of you who are
familiar with the scandal back in the
third week of November 1963 there was an
enormous scandal that engulfed Wall
Street in the first four days of that
week it was written about by a Wall
Street Journal reporter and it became a
book called the great salad oil swindle
and there was a guy by the name of Tino
DeAngelo's who had leased out empty
petroleum tankers in Bayonne New Jersey
and filled them with water and in the
little testing vials along the side put
in some salad oil and he then tried to
corner the global salad oil market by
suggesting that he had these tankers
filled with salad oil he borrowed
against the tankers of water from
American Express financial and to Wall
Street brokerage houses and then went
out and bought salad oil futures and
tried to corner the market and the whole
thing came undone in the third week of
November 1963 and created chaos on Wall
Street to brokerage firms were suspended
from doing business with the new york
stock exchange American Express
financial almost went out of business
and so it was a wild week in the market
already and by the time everyone got to
that Friday they were waiting really for
another financial shoe to drop and were
somewhat nervous but by the morning of
November 22nd the market had begun to
stabilize and things were looking a
little bit better but then in the middle
of the day our cash ins partner asked
have you seen anything about the
president that might explain this
renewed downdraft he hadn't and it turns
out as we all know that November 22nd is
a day that everybody who was alive at
the time remembers and is frozen in time
in many ways everyone knows where they
were what they were doing at that moment
and art recalls having not been able to
find any information that would explain
this behavior in the stock market and
set him really on a quest to understand
how sometimes markets can move in
advance of events that are later known
to the general public and it turned out
that the market did move and some
minutes later the ticker tapes ran the
headline of John F Kennedy being shot
and eventually killed and it's set out
on this quest to find out
how this had transpired and any learned
of this story which there are people
whose claim is still apocryphal and
others who say it's true art believes
firmly the story is true that on the day
of November 22nd 1963 there was a Dallas
brokerage house manager who led his
people go out to watch the motorcade
passed in the city which back in those
days was a fairly big deal you couldn't
watch it on CNBC or CNN or any national
television network it wasn't those one
of those events that would be televised
by the nature major networks just
because it wasn't a national event it
was really more a local event and your
local television station didn't
necessarily carry it live and you had to
go out and experience it if you wanted
to see it much unlike having the
president come to New York these days
where in some cases it's more of an
annoyance than it is a pleasure when the
West Side Highway is tied up for hours
on end back then it was kind of an
interesting experience and people go out
and see their president but he let his
staff out and no sooner did they leave
the office at lunch time that they turn
around and came back and the brokerage
house manager was a bit perplexed and he
looked at his staff and he said what
happened and so we don't know but the
motorcade was rerouted and we have no
idea why they were never close enough to
see what had transpired but they were
close enough to know that something had
changed and being a smart market type he
looked at his folks and said give me a
bullish reason why they would cancel in
1963 a presidential motorcade and people
came up with fairly flimsy excuses and
he said now give me a bearish reason and
given the climate of the times with
Russia and Cuba and a whole host of
other concerns that were at the
forefront of America's thinking he knew
instinctively that a cancelled parade
would have negative connotations not
only for the markets but maybe even
beyond that and called New York and said
sell and he got his clients out at
prices that would later turn out to be
much higher than he could have otherwise
gotten them out at later in the day in
fact it was one of the most chaotic and
frenetic days in stock market history
for those of you who are in the business
you know that in the space of 35 minutes
the market plunged on volume by the end
of the day that was greater than the
1929 crash and in the 35 minutes it was
one of the most unsettling experience
that anybody who participated in the
stock market had ever come across and
the various studies that were done later
by the New York Stock Exchange and the
Securities and Exchange Commission
no that it was by far and away one of
the most dramatic days that ever taken
place in the history of history of stock
trading in this country and as part of
my study it turned out that the market
could have in fact behaved in the manner
that art was trying to understand that
could be explained by the anecdote that
I shared with you there was a nine
minute gap between the first shot being
fired at the president and the first
headline that was carried on the ticker
tape so somebody who was close enough to
the event to know that something had
gone wrong might have been able to act
in a way that would have indicated
something but not fully explained the
situation now nine minute gap today is
unthinkable if the president were
driving today in an open motorcade
somewhere in this country and television
cameras were on him live there would be
virtually no gap in the general public
understanding what had happened and the
rest of the world getting the
information there would be no gap
between people in the know and people
out on the periphery as there was in
this case and so the market did begin to
turn before the headline ran and is
fully explained by the events of that
story and it got art Cashin thinking
about how markets working in a broader
sense now sometimes they will discount
or anticipate seemingly anticipate
political events like the one described
and other times the markets will
anticipate economic events long before
individuals come to understand what's
going on in the general economy and you
all know that from having stood at the
center of your universe for an entire
career that the markets seemed to know
and in fact in many cases always know
what's coming with respect to the
economy or in some cases political
developments as well a great example is
the behavior of oil in 1990 before the
Gulf War ever started before anybody
knew Saddam Hussein had designs on
kuwait oil went from fifteen dollars in
may of nineteen ninety to $25 by the
middle of July before there were even
rumors of Iraqi troop movements somebody
clearly knew that something was going on
that might be a market changing event
coming out of the Middle East in fact
Tom Friedman of the New York Times has
written about Saddam Hussein's somewhat
uncanny ability to buy oil futures
before he ginned up a little action with
the United Nations and the PO
war environment only to raise a little
hard currency by goosing the oil market
and then selling before he'd back down
against un demands and having taken his
profit so you have to assume that maybe
before saddam hussein invaded kuwait in
august of 1990 he might have bought some
oil futures for somebody who gases his
own people insider trading is probably
not the most egregious sin he could
commit and so we got a very potent
message from the oil market in the
spring and summer of nineteen ninety
that suggested something was afoot
sixty-six percent gain in oil in two
months that should have meant something
to somebody and yet the world was
entirely surprised on august second when
saddam hussein marched across the border
into kuwait and touched off the gulf war
and in fact oil prices for the remainder
of that experience were very very
prescient in suggesting what was the
likely outcome of the war you recall oil
peaked in october of 1990 just as the US
was finalizing its plans to liberate
kuwait and plunged on the first day of
the war as the pundits were saying that
this could be a long drawn-out affair
that it could be another Vietnam that
the United States was running up against
a foe the likes of which it hadn't seen
in quite a number of decades and yet oil
prices fell on the first day of the war
stock prices went up and it was a
remarkable event the dow went up five
percent in a single day the day that the
war started now if people thought this
was going to have smart people thought
that this was really going to be a
vietnam style event or worse why did
stocks go up well it seems that people
in the know the smart money crowd had
some inkling that this was going to be a
short rather dramatic and violent burst
of activity but that would end up in the
Allies favor and so it's this type of
thinking that led me to try to
understand why markets do what they do
how they do what they do and how we
sometimes get into environments like the
one that we were just in from nineteen
ninety five to two thousand where things
got a little crazy now the message of
the markets between 1995 and 2000 was
actually fairly benign we had
extraordinarily strong economic growth
very low inflation we had a new
technology that was transforming the
economy in a way that most people
understood and yet the market was very
good at discounting that
transformational event that was taking
place in the internet and the
telecommunications sector now
unfortunately for many of us it got to a
point where it
orient more than discount discounted and
more than anticipated all the future
revenues and all the future profits that
would be accrued to these new
technologies and that's the makings of a
bubble but during that period from
nineteen ninety five to nineteen ninety
nine there was a lot going on that was
positive and the markets were telling us
things that were in fact quite true that
we entered a new period of prosperity
that was one that was highly productive
and two it was highly beneficial to a
broad population but there was a moment
where that environment was transformed
into a bubble or Romania and that's the
subject I'd like to deal with today
because the part that is most striking
about all this is the repetitive nature
of these phenomenon known as bubbles or
manias or investment fats they recur
with great frequency in American
financial history and in fact in world
financial history you can go back to the
1630s and everyone knows these stories
about the tulip mania in Holland or the
various financial manias that took place
in Britain in France in the 1720s you
can go even farther back as Edward
Chancellor did in his book devil take
the hindmost and talk about speculation
and public companies in Rome in the
first century AD he found some evidence
that there was a fair amount of
speculation in the Roman stock market in
the first century which is now the
earliest date that we know that there
was this type of activity he's not been
able to find any evidence of bubbles but
there was some sort of manic activity
that took place as far back as that in
fact you can go even farther back into
ancient Mesopotamia and find futures
contracts on wheat and other grains you
can find mortgages you can find io io
u--'s and other sorts of derivative
financial products as far back as
ancient Mesopotamia so this type of
activities been going on for as long as
human beings have been economic
creatures hey des of quartz reached a
zenith in recent years and most recently
here in the United States say at its
peak in the year 2000 but it is a
recurring phenomenon and one from which
very few people ever learn any lessons
if you look at what happened between
1982 and the year 2000 there were at
least seven or eight bubbles of some
sort in some market that took place and
most people rejected the notion that
they were in
anyway similar or anyway relevant to the
experience we had in the late 1990s and
that's the issue that I address in trend
watching which is why is it that people
can't understand that this cyclical
phenomenon can be quite dangerous if you
want to ignore the history of bubbles
and manias as I say you can go very far
back to prove that they've existed then
you can come all the way forward to
understand what the significance is and
people in many ways reject out of hand
historical comparisons when you are in
the middle of a mania one of the things
i found that was was fascinating
actually in the 1840s was a mania which
happened along with the mania for
Turnpike's and canals companies that
build Turnpike's and canals back in the
1820s 1830s were very hot and their
bonds and the various public traded
securities of these companies were
involved in a mania that would be
duplicated later in railroads and
eventually in autos and a whole host of
other infrastructure type industries but
in the 1840s there was a mania in
companies that built plank roads wooden
plank roads that connected villages to
the urban centers of town now it doesn't
sound like high technology except at the
time it was the Russians invented it the
Canadians perfected it and the United
States imported the technology to build
these wooden plank board roads that were
supposed to be toll roads from which the
companies that built them would derive
huge unimaginable profits and revenues
over time and in fact the literature if
you'll pardon me while I read from the
book was very much like the literature
you would see a hundred and fifty years
later mrs. brief reading about how plank
roads were described in the 1840s plank
roads are emphatically the people roads
they can use them regularly to fit their
own convenience they promote social
intercourse among neighbors afford ready
dispatch for medical relief in case of
sickness by a bridging distance and
remove all occasion for excuse to attend
religious worship and bad weather every
important movement in locomotion
benefits society morally intellectually
and not only tends to expedite
interchanges in various productions of
the soil in the arts read that business
but increases intercourse and removes
the local and provincial prejudices and
the slicks together the social fabric
with stronger and more lasting bonds let
me read you something that Al Gore said
about the internet about 150 or
later if we had the information
superhighway that we need a child could
plug into the Library of Congress every
afternoon and explore a universe of
knowledge a doctor in Carthage Tennessee
could consult with experts at the Mayo
Clinic on a patient's cat scan in the
middle of an emergency teams of
scientists and engineers working on the
same problem in different geographic
locations could work in a co laboratory
if the supercomputers were linked we are
witnessing the emergence of a truly
global civilization based on shared
knowledge in the form of the digital
code it's exactly the same statement and
in fact the intensity with which people
greeted the plank road technology was
equal to that of the internet plank road
companies went public there were several
thousand I said 1300 that went public in
that period and most of them went bust
one of the promises that they made with
plank roads was that they would be so
profitable that they would deliver a
return on the investment of ten to
fifteen percent in perpetuity because
the roads would last 15 years or longer
the problem with wooden plank board
roads is that they rotted in about four
years and had to replaced very quickly
the cost of replacing were excessive if
a horse broke its leg on a rotted piece
of wood you suddenly had business
actually suffering higher costs for
having used the roads than not and so
the promise was not ultimately delivered
and these companies crashed in the
public markets and many many people lost
money as they would later in railroads
as they would in radio as they would in
the automobile as they would later in
transistors in the 1960s biotechnology
stocks computer stocks in 1980s you
picked the mania but when it was an
infrastructure development or some new
technology people greeted it with the
notion that the profits would be
limitless and the returns also would be
equally limitless never understanding
that these bubbles break for some reason
whether it's higher interest rates
whether the technology fails to deliver
on the promise there is something that
cracks the market and suddenly
reconnects the economic reality of the
new technology to the way the markets
have priced in those future profits and
that is the thing that people always
forget at the end that the stock and the
fundamental reality of the company can
become divorced and that at some price
at some point this
aqua price in more than all the future
revenues or profits available to the
company and that terminal value is hit
and the stocks will crash it happened
was radio in the 1920s happen with
bicycle companies in the 1890s now it
wasn't a publicly traded phenomenon but
there were 300 bicycle companies that
were built in the 1890s and it totally
displaced the horse horse sales plunged
when the bicycle became the dominant
mode of transportation in the 1890s and
that was immediately displaced by
automobiles by 1905 the auto had wiped
out the bicycle business in the United
States so that of the 300 companies that
were created only a handful were left so
you get the sense that this behavior
this this mania for infrastructure
development or new technology in some
ways is entirely normal in the American
financial experience but it is also
extraordinarily repetitive and people
never learned the lesson of when to get
out when to limit their exposure to
these new technologies we were derided
those of us who were talking about these
phenomenon making these comparisons in
the mid to late 1990s as being luddites
is not understanding that the internet
was so transformational it was nothing
like radio didn't matter that RCA went
from three dollars a share in 1923 to
600 by 1929 and back to three by 1935
radio was not applicable even though it
was the internet of its day there were
four hundred and eighty publicly traded
automobile companies in the 1920s there
are three today no one can argue that
the automobile was any less
transformational than the Internet to
the way the American economy behaved and
yet people forget that this process
takes place that people get too excited
about the new technology so much so
they're willing to play pay any price to
participate and yet the promise in the
economy is very real the stock market
returns could be entirely different from
what people assume will likely take
place over time in fact we're talking
about what could be the new bubble at
the very end of the book which might be
in real estate and there are a lot of
people debating whether or not we're
going to a national real estate bubble
anytime soon and one of the interesting
things about bubbles is they do change
shape in such a way that you can
immediately forget your last experience
if the next bubble is in real estate
everyone will immediately say hey this
is not comparable to the internet I can
own my own home it's a physical asset
the fact that it's going up at a rate
much faster than inflation is much
different than internet stocks going up
at rates much faster than inflation this
is a physical asset that I can own and
will always go up we may get to that
point in the American economy where
people believe real estate is the new
short thing in fact in today's Wall
Street Journal buyers get free down
payments on homes paid for by builders
one of the things that we've found doing
the book is that one of the
preconditions for a bubble to exist is
very easy money that there's a lot of
free cash floating around i mean the
internet was financed by very easy money
the fed was easy stock market was going
up so the currency became very cheap
internet companies can buy other
internet companies for virtually no cost
because they had a currency that was
constantly rising in value now that's
not true in the stock market anymore but
it might end up being true in real
estate somebody can buy a hundred and
forty eight thousand dollar home in
Middle America with a gift from a
charitable foundation that is backed by
the Builder who in turn reimburses the
charitable foundation for that gift and
you've got a zero down situation and the
default risk in the real estate market
grows because people who wouldn't
normally qualify to invest in the house
are suddenly able to do so just as
people who were normally not qualified
to trade stocks did so in great numbers
by march of 2000 when we saw the advent
of the individual day trader really
become the most important player in the
market individuals set the price in the
stock market in 1999-2000 which made
institutional investors crazy they were
so used to being the incremental buyer
or the marginal buyer and setting that
price that a lot of them had no idea
what to do once the individual was the
dominant force in the marketplace
individuals can be very dominant in real
estate and this may be the area to watch
going forward so with that one bit of
prognostication i'd be happy to answer
any questions and talk about maybe some
of the examples that exist in the book
or the conditions that surround bubbles
frequently in this country and i know
it's early but feel free to grab a
microphone and and fire away if you like
who wants to kick it off you'll be on
c-span i should point out
ronnie was doing not to play trends no
I'm not arguing not to play chance I'm
arguing that people should pay attention
to the indications that suggests a trend
is maturing one of the interesting
things about the end of a bubble is that
is usually fairly easy to spot with only
one simple rule and it's a Marty swag
rule which is don't fight the Fed if
people had exited the stock market when
the Federal Reserve began raising
interest rates in 1999 they would have
kept all their profits they didn't even
pay attention to that one simple rule
suddenly the one most dominant rule of
investing that's existed for all time in
American financial history which is to
not be in equities when interest rates
are going up was totally ignored because
of the notion that it's different this
time and that is the one most dangerous
line that wall street has created which
is it's that different this time when
you hear that you should sell everything
you have because it's the only way
you're going to get out hole and on top
of that when you see the Fed actively
trying to cool down the economy or
inflation in the stock market as it
might have been described at the time
that's the time that you should get out
and no one did we argued very
aggressively with people over this very
topic economists would tell you hey
rising interest rates don't mean the
same thing in this environment than they
have in other periods and yet they
always do and people still fail to
understand the historical significance
of of a shift in the fundamental
environment and stayed too long you know
you bought Cisco at 84 in 1999 or early
2000 while the Fed was raising interest
rates you traded it down to 10 there is
no telling not to pick on Cisco how long
it's going to take for that stock to go
back to the price at which you purchased
it you bought it an environment where
you shouldn't have been buying stocks
now I'm going to have something of a
preacher zeal with respect to this if I
can save one person I'll feel that I've
done some sort of service obviously the
nature of a bubble is it it is mass
delusion and you can't save everybody
but if you can get a couple people to
understand the trends don't go on
forever then I think you've done
investors something of a service yes sir
and if they could wait for the
microphone what you just said what
said I believe is now the opposite
interest rates are at forty year lows
the Cisco is ten dollars or whatever it
is at this stage but it's much lower
than 84 right so one would say we're at
the opposite of 1999 so we should be
loading up one stops hey loading up as a
strong word I mean I think the one thing
you do have to go back with respect to
this particular environment is look at
history in a post bubble environment
which can be somewhat anomalous relative
to to what we see normally take place
when the feds lowering interested but
only two other times in memory that most
people share of when the Fed was
lowering interest rates or when a
central bank was lowering interest rates
and stocks didn't go up and that would
be Japan throughout the 1990s the United
States in the early 1930s I mean the Fed
up until this most recent cut had
reduced interest rates 11 times and the
stock market went to lower lows that
hadn't happened in this country since
the 1930s so you do have to be somewhat
respectful of the historical comparisons
it is pretty obvious that stocks had
become inexpensive in price terms
whether or not they become an expensive
and valuation terms is entirely other
question my cisco made trade at 10 but
the Pease might still be 50 and if
they're not growing twenty-five or
thirty percent you are you willing to
pay fifty times earnings for a company
that's not growing nearly as fast as it
used to if it's growing at all at the
moment its profitable but more so on
cost-cutting than to end market share
than it is on on pure top-line growth
yes sir no my question is pendulums work
both ways in your book do you address
the idea of a fat or pendulum Wars mania
swinging to the extreme opposite over to
you if you address the mania on the
upside I thought on the downside oh sure
I mean we're in the middle of it right
now Japan's in the middle of it and
hopefully not in the middle of it maybe
at the end of that that that pendulum
swing right now where the Nikkei went
from 39,000 on the last day of 1989 to
as low as 8300 most recently I mean
after 12 years the Nikkei was still
making lower lows and markets overshoot
in both directions we know that the hard
part is picking
turning point and I think the obviously
people might want to start thinking
about reinvesting in stocks here and
making more of a commitment given what's
transpired and we only took the Dow
three years to make its its absolute low
from nineteen twenty nine to nineteen
thirty-two and if you were to purchase
stocks at that point then the next 20
some odd years 23 years we've been a
fabulous tried the Dow then went from 32
all the way back to 381 by 1954 so you
have to have been able however to
weather the storms that were ushered in
by the crash and maybe remember 1937
wasn't a Bismil year and the market
crashed again didn't go back to 32 but
it crashed again 1941 was the start of
World War two and you would have to
weather that storm and everything that
went along with it and yet stocks net
net went up just have to understand that
the market might feel different the
environment might feel different having
purchased at the bottom and then trying
to to ride the wave back up it won't be
that secular type of bull market that
you had necessarily when things were
good but prices will tend to rise don't
talk as much about that in this book as
I'm trying to get people to focus on the
recurring nature of these events and how
to avoid the psychology that traps
people in a particular investment
because it's going to happen again we
just don't know what the asset class is
you know happened in gold and silver in
the early 1980s in the United States and
people hocked the family silver because
they wanted to take advantage of fifty
dollar prices you know they got to that
point where they were willing to let go
with family heirlooms because silver was
at fifty dollars an ounce and going to a
hundred and go was going to go from 800
to over a thousand and oil was going to
go from 35 to a hundred dollars a barrel
people get crazy they engage in
something called linear extrapolation
where they just assume that the trend in
place goes on forever and people fail to
think about inflection points and what
I'm trying to do here is try to get
people to think about that but things
change and to recognize when things
change when one thing that I suggest is
you know buy and hold is this wall
street creation a marketing tool and the
everybody says warren buffett is a
buy-and-hold investor he's not he is a
by and watch investor he never just
drawers his stock for 30 years and
assumes everything will be okay he
manages his portfolio he pays attention
and if something doesn't work he sells
it something changes he
sells them something that's very cheap
he buys more of it if it's appropriate
but there's no such thing as just you
know taking hold of a technology stock
at whatever price and assuming that when
you retire it's going to be worth
infinitely more than when you bought it
as a very dangerous philosophy and I
think that's what really grip people in
the 1990s yes sir you know real estate
being the next possible bubble and all
of us being real estate owners I'm sure
have a concern about that but I think
with the problems that have occurred in
the last few years you remember your mom
and dad saying as a kid Jesus own your
house if you own your house you're a
success so to buy real estate it's a
tangible item that you own real estate
probably the worst job ever I guess was
in Houston in the 60s if I recall in
this country tell me a txt and the 80s
down twenty eight percent roughly I
think buying real estate i'm looking at
i'm saying to myself after the fears
that have taken place in the last couple
years Jesus buy buy real estate what's
my downside twenty-eight percent right
versus what's my downside if i buy risky
stocks and get caught up in it so for a
guy like me that's and let's call it tag
ends of a career if you want to call it
that it's saying like I'm oz will lock
into some tangible items like real
estate and or tax-free municipal bonds
at ridiculous rates and just sit back
and watch things happen opposed to
jumping in to a situation it may be
uncomfortable real estate being my
choice only because history has told me
there's a certain percentage to the
downside right and that's all true and
one of the problems with real estate is
not so much buying and owning a house
just as in many cases it isn't buying
and owning a good stock outright it's
the leverage employed in the decision
and people tend to get very loose about
their buying standards when things get
hot and that was even true in real
estate if you look at the example took
place in Southern California in the
1970s and 1980s people got crazy about
owning homes they got into the first
house and would go to new developments
on the outskirts of Los Angeles sleep
overnight at these developments so they
can get in on a starter home six months
later they'd sell it and move up and you
got this kind of speculative manic
behavior that went along with real
estate we're only
anecdotal evidence that that's true in
selected markets in this country right
now people flipping condos in Miami or
buying second homes by using borrowed
money from their first house in order to
buy a more speculative second home
vacation house or property they're going
to fix up and sell it's that type of
behavior I'm more concerned with I mean
if you're going to own a primary
residence sure it's a great thing there
are huge tax benefits it's a smart thing
to do if you're going to own a vacation
home it is a smart thing to do assuming
that you're going to live there and use
it and not try to trade in and out of
the market what I worry about is at some
point because people are so
disenfranchised and disillusioned with
the stock market which is the hallmark
of the flip side of a bubble is that
they try to recreate that magic in
another asset and in some cases it might
end up being real estate now we don't
know it could be anything it could be
overseas stocks you know China is still
in some ways hot and it's going to be
that thing that you can't explain really
well and then people get very excited
about it or biotech has a chance at
coming back or nanotechnology there's
going to be something that gets people's
you know enthusiasm and interest going
again and they'll forget all the rules
that they should have learned during
this last route I mean hey in the 1990s
when 4kids entertainment was so hot
because of the pokemon craze when we
talked about the stock getting too
expensive relative to the business that
was being generated you would not
imagine the angry emails and phone calls
that you would get talking about how the
stock can't go up forever that the kids
don't naturally adhere themselves to a
trading card or playing card craze for
their entire lifetime you know what
happened in for kids entertainment was
the same that happened in amazon com or
AOL there was a point at which you
needed more people or more kids than
there were on this planet to support the
valuation of stock somebody had done
analysis of amazon and AOL that they
needed subscriber growth that would have
included every other planet in our solar
system to justify the valuation and you
knew you weren't going to get it so if
all six billion people on this planet
had used any of these services on a
regular basis that still wouldn't
justify the infinite multiple and you
don't want to get to that point in real
estate what I just think is that people
are so disillusioned right now they're
going to look for that other asset that
provides more security more higher rates
of return and that might generate the
same
type of enthusiasm and people will again
suspend their disbelief yes ma'am I was
in the broker-dealer community in the
early 90s during the gaming craze which
was about a nine to twelve month type of
bubble during the internet bubble I was
actually living in Australia working in
the securities industry there and it
just seemed to be such an attenuated
timeframe although really similar to the
gaming stock flailing do you see those
bubbles becoming more attenuated or more
compacted or will it really depend on
what it is well you kind of to
differentiate among the fads and manias
and bubbles I mean that the gaming thing
was a fad just like themed restaurants
just like you know for kids
entertainment if you look at you know
Pokemon it was also like cabbage patch
kids beanie babies Furbys there are
these attenuated smaller scale events
that don't have the type of macro
economic impact that a full-scale bubble
has and yet the behavior the chart
patterns the suspension of disbelief the
speculative activity is all very similar
and during the the beanie baby craze if
you look at price histories of beanie
babies which you know if you got spare
time feel free but these were two dollar
99 cent toys you know made overseas for
probably two or three cents apiece that
at their height sold individually for
five thousand dollars each and you know
the action on ebay was frenetic that you
had to get the one bear or the one
elephant that was never going to be
recreated by Ty Warner again and you
know God knows you needed own it because
in 20 years it was gonna be worth fifty
thousand dollars they're all worth at
best a hundred twenty dollars in some
cases back to 299 after having been
worth on paper an extraordinary amount
of money so you have bubbles you have as
much smaller trends but the the
hallmarks are all the characteristics
are all identical that's the shocking
part it doesn't even matter the size of
the bubble the behavior the environment
is exactly the same for a large scale
bubble that has true policy significance
down to these little tiny bubbles as we
call them in the book that don't but but
they're very similar across the board
yes sir wrong would you
we all know that in 74 and market was
that it was at an amazing low and it
took approximately 20 years to probably
begin this bubble which I believe was
probably around 94 right Marcus starting
it better in India tease but I really
never got to go like it did in 94 so
although the 82 to 87 experience was
pretty impressive but just didn't have
public participation as part of the
process yeah yeah and I didn't feel that
that would necessarily a bubble like I
was in there 90 my question really is do
you think it will take another
approximately 20 years before we'll see
or because we move in such quick time
today will it be much quicker than that
I don't know the QuickTime element of it
I tend to doubt because any particular
group of people are operating as fast as
they can possibly operate them in the
1920s was extraordinarily quick for
people who grown up in the teens you
know so the new technological
developments when you think about what's
going on the ticker tape radio
experiments with television the
automobile bullying being fully rolled
out in the United States those were
extraordinary technical technological
achievements that made everybody feel
they were moving as fast as they could
possibly move now granted our technology
has increased the pace dramatically but
I'm not sure that it's necessarily going
to shorten the cycle between those macro
bubbles I mean they tend to be
generational events and the 20s in a lot
of ways weren't the last one you
mentioned the 70s that process the the
bull market that took place from the
early 1960s through 1973 was a fairly
long one public participation got as
high in 1968 is it had ever been in this
country forty percent of individuals own
stock either directly or through mutual
funds in that period which was just less
than what we experienced most recently
and that took a generation in a
disinvestment from the peak in 1968 to
the low in 1982 or mutual fund Holdings
had fallen all the way back and to
levels that existed before the mania and
you know a lot of you folks have been
around for a while the go-go days what
we're very much like what we experienced
in the nineties I mean people had to own
mutual funds I talked about it a
cocktail parties you know was a national
craze national pastime but I think
type of bubble will take a while to
recur yeah run you start your talk by
talking about a nine minute gap before
you got news today during your day job
you have instantaneous news I put that
in quotes because sometimes it's an
accurate and clearly fads manias and
many bubbles are created instantaneously
by you people who do the same thing you
do on your day job how do you protect
the public against that kind of instant
information instant response instant
action so first of all the public has to
want to be protected which in the late
1990s they didn't and I'll get to that
in a second but these manias have
happened without a real time financial
media in the past I mean if you go back
to the 1630s when the tulip craze was
fully enforced there were newsletters
there were newspapers but there was no
24-hour real-time media telling people
to buy tulips this happened by word of
mouth that happened you know it may not
have been as large scale of phenomenon
as people think based on some of the
historical accounts but these things
have happened without the aid of a CNBC
you know the the the various manias that
took place in 1700s in Britain France
the railroad crates here you pick it I
mean there were there was no cable
television operation that was dedicated
solely to the delivery of financial news
now addressing a question more
specifically there were many of us who
talked about these examples during the
bubble taking place and yet we're still
dealing with issues of whether or not we
were cheerleaders for the process now I
put up the chart of RCA I believe
probably in 1997 I know I was the first
person using on the air didn't come from
me it came from one of my sources who
was looking at these analogs but we
showed our CA as being this you know
phenomenon of the 1920s it was very much
analogous to the internet and people got
very angry and accused me of not
understanding the environment that I was
in at the end of 1999 I wrote a piece
for CNBC about how the market may be in
a blow-off phase dangerously topping out
got no response at all it had gotten to
the point where no one even cared that I
was saying it sunday they stop getting
angry they just entirely stopped
listening so while the media can have an
amplification effect of some sort you
know this megaphone that's out there and
may reinforce in some ways that
and that's in place you you can't also
as hard as you try to point point out
that it's not a rational environment
people stopped listening when Keitel
announced that it was shifting from a
company that sold bad 70's music over
the telephone to a company that sold bad
70's music over the internet we had the
CEO on and we buried the guy on
television and the stock went up as soon
as the interview was over I don't know
what you do in that environment when
everybody's willing to suspend suspend
their disbelief even the media as
powerful as it may seem can't turn that
psychological trend around something has
to take place that will change it now of
course you don't get any credit on the
flip side for having setting these
things most people are still angry then
it all came to an end and of course
blame the media so that's one of the
problems being the messenger they shoot
you at the end of the game at last
question yes sir you mentioned real
estate is a bubble a possible bubble
more money is flowing into the bond
market than any other source the bond
interest rates are at 40 year lows is
there a bubble in the bond market yeah
it's a different kind of bubble it it
doesn't have all the same
characteristics that the stock market
bubble have had people aren't buying
bonds because they think the returns are
going to be so phenomenal that they have
to own bonds they're buying bonds as
almost a last resort investment just to
protect some capital and certainly
what's going on in the refinancing arena
has created additional pressure on
institutions to own bonds because of the
various dislocations that occur when
people refinance their homes you know on
a mass scale it's a bubble of sorts and
no doubt there's going to be a year of
terrible performance for the bond market
interest rates might just shoot up
because the unwinding of all these
various ownership structures in the bond
market will take place as rapidly as
they were put in place and we saw that
1993 1994 rates went as far down as they
could and then the flip side when the
Fed started raising was to wipe the bond
market out in 1994 was the worst year in
bonds since 1927 I imagine the 2003 we
might see a similar phenomenon and
people will lose money on bonds not
knowing that you could lose money on
bonds that's the big risk here as
individuals probably aren't as familiar
with the principal losses they could
take
in the bond market as they were in the
stock market even though they didn't
care so much about it in stocks they're
entirely unfamiliar with it and bonds so
there could be another area of
disillusion that there that takes place
in 2003 absolutely one thank you all for
your time was pleasure speaking here
today thank you Ron in sauna is host of
the CNBC program street signs bende
author of trend watching it's published
by Harper business and imprint of
harpercollins visit HarperCollins com
for more information